Taggart transcontinental is done what
are you talking about we can't stop and
we can't go on in a matter of weeks our
stock won't be trading anymore you're
being completely paranoid you can throw
it away a little bit okay Taggart
transcontinental is done what are you
talking about Henry Rearden claims that
his steel is lighter than even the
cheapest brands but it's ten times
stronger this is physically impossible
Jim you're inviting disaster if you use
it dagnine's now well something has to
be done
agreed I believe you know Wesley mouch
riddens man and wash you know what I
like about you Wesley
hear one word man true I'm the lobbyist
in Washington who tries to screw their
railroad plans we should do it from the
inside
what would take of transcontinental get
in return National Council of metal
Industries has completed a report
against Rearden metal written by Bertram
Scudder Paul this is not personal I'm
trying to con Taggart everybody has to
share the burdens we face even Reardon
I like doing that and then the bad guys
are always the best parts if you don't
have a good bad guy then you know it
kind of diminishes the strength of the
hero and with Dagny being the hero James
Taggart will connive he'll use political
posturing he will use whatever he can do
to get the upper hand
isn't that for instance mutiny Francisco
d'Anconia he's the guy inside that we
all want to be he may be a slacker but
he makes business investments that pay
off don't confuse him with a womanizer
because he's a man that has a center
what is such a great businessman the why
isn't single train filled with aura left
Mexico yet he's now invested in but he
also bought in himself it must not
something well the success of my Mexican
expansion depends on those mines or
James is not a thoughtful individual at
all he thinks he's kind of he believes
in these things we're really all he's
interested in is just destroying things
and eventually just destroys himself
you